is it called what do you cost
um it depends so in half an hour an hour
about overnight is that cleaning sorry
we're talking about yeah
because the dominatrix is non-sexual not
as touchy you're basically a goddess in
there as you know it's not like a
schooling service it's not like that so
overnight I charge 1.5 k for an hour 300
pounds with 100 pound deposit and that's
not even including the extras because
they want me to do really dirty things I
put their head in the toilet or maybe
poo on them I'm not ashamed of it I've
done it you I have done it no one's ever
done it to me but I have done it to them
and I'll admit that you um time ago yeah
was he a good looking guy yeah he
actually he actually was he actually was
it
feels more wrong when they're good
looking for some reason because it feels
like they shouldn't even be there